um briefly to start i wanted to mention
that we
have been making some progress with the
research
outcomes of this program and i hope that
some of you that are participating in
the program are continuing to
make your projects ready for different
poster presentations or even
publications
and as an example i'll start with
sharing just a few details about a
poster that we presented
at the recent louisiana biomedical
research network
bioinformatics annual conference
because it actually shares some
similarities with the topic of today's
webinar
so in this poster we focused
on a new data set that was uh
collected and sequenced by
the naguchi memorial institute for
medical research
anita ganza's group and
that was done primarily by benedictine
mensa
but the focus of the poster was on the
interaction of the apical membrane
antigen rotary neck protein to binding
which are candidates for vaccines
and so what's important about the
efficacy of these vaccines is the
genetic diversity
of this particular end of the antigen
which is the ama1
protein so one of the things that we
wanted to
investigate in this project was the
mutational signatures that actually
define this diversity
and one of the ways to define this
diversity is to take a look
at the variance in the perspective of
haplotypes and so i think this is a good
connection to the project that we'll be
talking about today because it also
speaks about haplotypes but a little bit
in a different context so again what is
plasmodium vociferum for all of you that
are probably familiar it's a parasite
actually so that
invades red blood cells and that causes
the clinical manifestation of the
disease called
the malaria and
in the context of real prevention many
different approaches have been taken
including anti-malaria drugs
that cause eventually the emergence of
resistance
uh there are preventive measures like
mosquito nets and eradication of
mosquitoes and and things like that and
so that reduces the transmission
and then one of the major additional
focuses
now is the vaccine approach and so the
vaccine approach has not been as
successful as
a lot of people have hoped for in the
past
and that is primarily again linked to
this
challenge of diversity and the genetic
diversity
allows the parasite any kind of an
infection pathogen to evade
detection of the immune system which has
been trained on a particular type of an
antigen
and the idea of
kind of suppressing so increased immune
pressure
on that parasite or on that pathogen
is a pressure that results in evolution
uh kind of selection of a particular
type of a particular strain
so what we did in this project and i
think this is
going to be evident how this is similar
to the project that we'll be talking
about today
is take uh assembled sequences
that already have been assembled from
the reference from mapping of those
sequencing reads onto the reference
genomes and then
from looking at all of the possible
variations
creating these haplotypes and so the
haplotypes in this case
refer to assembled sequences that
contain
multiple mutational signatures which
means that they
contain specific mutations
that occur together right and that was
one of the things that was done
to characterize population structure
because one of the hypotheses that
were pursued in this project was whether
this
genetic structure actually defines
uh kind of the prevalence of disease or
this
infection and so as a result we looked
at independently
occurring mutations and then we looked
at haplotypes which were connected into
a network and we tried to ask the
question well could we find haplotypes
that are unique
or more prevalent in a population and as
a result we've identified some
interesting trends so those mutational
signatures could be
affecting in a specific pattern they
could be affecting t
cell and b cell receptors and especially
this
could have an impact on the binding
between these two proteins
but i think that this experience kind of
validates this approach of taking
mutations as uh kind of the
result of immune pressure so again b
cell and t
cell receptors monitoring how they could
be potentially affected by mutations
is allowing us to look at mutational
pressures
and then thinking about haplotypes we're
not just thinking about
uh kind of random occurrence but
actually trying to
investigate how evolutionary pressures
caused this process of selection to
bring up some of those
haplotype sequences and then we could
focus on whether those sequences
are associated with a phenotype right so
for example if our phenotype is
transmission
or a phenotype is a kind of
manifestation of more acute or more
severe disease
those are then the downstream steps that
we could try to link
the molecular kind of profiles and
signatures that we identify
with the outcome but in the context of
viral
diseases and bacterial diseases we
actually have
several different educational projects
that we have prepared for
this program called bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
and so one of the projects included in
this program and included
in this kind of
analysis of viral genomic sequences
is this idea of a pathogen
that is affected by these haplotypes so
these are some of the other um projects
that we've covered already extensively
in the program and i'll briefly kind of
describe what these are so
uh there's a project called our origins
and pathogenesis of the novel
coronaviruses
virus you can find this project on our
new portal called learn.oxlogic.com
so for those of you that are new to our
sessions i welcome you to
explore that uh portal register for free
and explore some of these projects there
uh we of course dealt
extensively with ebola and the uh
pandemic in the ebola pandemic in 2014
2016
is an example of a pandemic where
genomic sequencing has been prevalent
and used extensively for the first time
to characterize
almost in real time the spread of the
disease and kind of changes that
occurred
in that virus and then we have some
additional ones that we've used
including
a an analysis of tuberculosis infection
for drug resistance
this is another idea of fitness or
low frequency mutations that cause the
viral
infection to act as a
kind of a collection of swarm of viruses
and their diversity
kind of correlating with the fitness
with the ability of the virus to cause
disease and then we also have some other
applications in biotechnology
for um detection of viral strains using
next generation sequencing
transcriptomic data so please take a
look at these
and then the project that we will be
talking about today
as biepsa mentioned is about enterovirus
d68 so
enterovirus d68 is a single strand
stranded positive sense rna virus that
belongs
to the enterovirus genus of the picorna
virude family evd68 infection
usually leads to severe respiratory
illness and has recently been reported
to be linked to the development of the
neurogenic disease
known as acute flaccid myelitis or afm
mostly in children so what it is is
essentially
the virus going through the respiratory
system
and entering the nervous system which is
a major concern with polio and other
entire viruses
and so that is a particular type of
a virus that can go between
these evolutionary and membership
and sorry evolutionary and
tissue specific membranes essentially
that are designed to prevent from
viruses to cross over between different
tissues
and so this phenomenon suggests that a
potential for evd68 to
induce nervous system disease arousing
widespread concern among
health authorities and the public
despite the fact that evd68 associated
infection was previously considered
infrequent
since 2005 it has undergone a worldwide
burst of growth in the u.s
asia and europe evd68 was first isolated
in california in 1962 from respiratory
samples of four pediatric patients
suffering from acute respiratory
syndromes
the ebd68 genome is about 7.6 kilobases
long similar to poly about eight
kilobases long
and consists of a single open reading
frame or flanked by
uh by untranslated regions
the genome encodes a precursor
polyprotein that is further
catalytically cleaved
resulting in four structural proteins
vp1
vp2 vp3 vp4 and seven
non-structural proteins 2a to b to c
3 a 3 b 3 c and 3 d
so there are some drugs um that have
been approved
and this is based on the understanding
of how these bind
to uh to the
surface proteins that are found
where infection happens so as you can
see right here we have the phylogenetic
tree and so we have the entire viruses
so the entire viruses include
enteroviruses like
evd and you can see 68 there are
polio viruses which are entire viruses c
kakasaki
so evb 3 and then they're also together
with
rhinoviruses so the difference between
rhinoviruses and these enteroviruses
is that uh they rhinoviruses primarily
cause
respiratory disease and entire viruses
typically cause
disease in the gut and that's where the
word
entero comes from and so
recently they have been grouped together
because they actually have a very high
similarity
in their sequence so to understand the
spread
of this recent potential
spread of this dangerous genome let's go
ahead and take a look
at this next strain
link so i'm just going to go over uh to
next strain i hope that many of you are
familiar with next string
uh this is the link i'll just post it in
the chat box so please let me know once
you reach this link
it will show us the evolution of
enterovirus from 1985 or 1986 actually
when it was first sequenced in
california as mentioned
and all the way up until now so please
put
something like number one uh in the chat
box so i know that you are there
okay and uh as everybody is getting
there please let me know
uh if you're already familiar with neck
strain
put number two if you're not familiar
with neck strain
then don't put anything so i will know
how many people are actually familiar
with neck string
okay so not a lot of people i don't see
a lot of answers
to number two so i don't know how many
are actually familiar with
neck strain what next strain
shows is the phylodynamics of
enterovirus and one of the things to
make it really dynamic we can do here is
we can actually
play this sequence
to see what happens year by year so you
can see here the slider
is moving and it's showing us the
occurrence
in united states where it was first
detected
then we see in canada in france
we see an increase in the united states
but also on this side you can see
how the clades of this phylogenetic tree
start
separating into distinct groups as it
spreads
in europe and then you can see in asia
and then you can see this
large emergence of this red circle right
here which is in the united states
and so what we are looking at these uh
sequences right here or this particular
region
you can see it happened right around
2014
2015 okay so what this shows us
is the divergence of specific sequences
what this shows us are the number of
uh those uh individual genome sequences
present by location so for example red
dots
are in the us and let's say green dots
right here
are in sweden and so we're going to be
actually looking at some of those
sequences today
down here you can see the genome so
remember we talked about
vb4 vp2 vp3 and vp1 so these are the
structural proteins and then these are
the non-structural proteins
2a to c 3 a 3 b 3 c
and 3 d so we just talked about these
what you can see here is diversity so
how
specific positions on the sequence
have either higher mutability right they
tend to mutate
more or less and actually
if you scroll down here you can also
download the data so all this data is
available
and for those of you that are interested
could you can actually
install this to run this on your custom
sequences so
this is uh the phylodynamics of
enterovirus
d68 so you can kind of see how it
evolved over the years
go back to my presentation
okay so the evd68 wasn't always
in the spot in the highlight poliovirus
the causative agent of polio
myelitis was discovered in 1908
and poliovirus infection can result in a
variety of symptoms
including afp or afm which is acute
flaccid
paralysis or myelitis that cause
lifelong disability and may cause death
right so everybody kind of remembers
polio
and one of the major things that
happened were the
vaccines against polio so the first
poliovirus vaccine was an
inactivated injectable vaccine developed
by jonas salk
in 1955 the second vaccine administered
orally was a vaccine developed by albert
sabin
in 1961 introduction
of poliovirus vaccine reduced infections
dramatically with only small
outbreaks occurring sporadically acute
flaccid myelitis afm is a
polio-like illness defined by the acute
onset of flaccid paralysis
in the setting spinal mra demonstrating
a longitudinal lesion in the gray matter
of the core so you can see right here
this lesion right here is what is caused
by
this disease so that's the clinical
manifestation
and the majority of patients with evd68
infections show
symptoms of mild respiratory illness
however
co-occurrences of evd68 and polio-like
neurological symptoms established evd68
as an emerging pathogen
before 2014 the evd68
outbreaks were sporadic and only
resulted in 29 cases in the us
and 699 cases in europe between 1970 and
2005. in 2014 the usa experienced the
largest known
evd68 outbreak in history with 120 cases
of
afm particularly in young children
confirmation of afm required
this mri scan and so you could then
determine by looking at a picture like
this that there was actually
a damage in this spinal cord
tissue
and so we also know that as we saw in
the previous
figure we saw that the clades emerge
and so these clades have names and the
subplate
b1 that is associated with afm has 12
substitutions that carry the same
residues observed
at the same positions and paralysis
causing enterovirus
d71 or poliovirus subplate b3
is now associated with afm the
hypothesis states that evd68 acquired
pathogenicity
after the furman strain was isolated in
2014 there were outbreaks in europe as
well in france norway and
uk in 2016 a new upsurge in the number
of evd68 cases occurred first in the
netherlands
from many patients one was presented
with afm
phylogenetic analysis revealed the
isolated the isolate belonged to a
different subclass than 2014
outbreaks isolates okay so let's take a
look again
at um this
at this next strain right here and so
you will see these names right again
subplate so you have here b1
b3 b2 b etc so what what is
the history of these clades so you have
right around 2000
maybe 1998 these plates separated
into clades a b or a and c
so right here and then this clade
separated into b
and c and we can see here how
this has a lot of cases in 2014 and now
we're talking about a new set of
emerging cases in 2016
right around here and you can see that a
lot of them are
in sweden so these are cases that
primarily happen in
europe not as much in in the us and here
you see
a lot of these are in the us okay so
now we're looking at these different
claims let's understand
what these mutations have the potential
to do so why
why are we looking for these mutations
okay so to understand these mutations we
need to understand the mechanism
of infection so the existence of cyanic
acid
on the surface of human respiratory
tract endothelial
cells may be the reason for effective
replication of evd68
neuroaminodase was shown to catalyze the
hydrolysis of cyanic acid reducing
attachment of evd68 cells
to hela cells up to 90 percent
indicating that it might be a receptor
for evd68 however some strains of evd68
from 2014
were resistant to neuroaminodase
treatment
and that suggests that there's an
alternative receptor
a novel receptor for evd68 was
identified in 2016
as an intracellular adhesion molecule 5
or icam-5
okay so you can see icams are this
are these uh receptors on
airway epithelium and they also
are receptors for human rhinovirus and
here you can see
that again remember enteroviruses the
word entero comes from they enter the
gut and rhinoviruses typically infect
the
respiratory system and so here we can
see this
so icam 5 is highly expressed in
mammalian
uh in mammalian telencephalon
of the central nervous system whereas
other icams are abundant in lymphocytes
i can 1 and i can 3 endothelial cells i
can 1 and i can 2
epithelial cells i can 1 and
erythrocytes i can
4 and so that's where we kind of see
this change from maybe the regular way
that this
virus infects
infects humans and
eventually this you can see here was
published
in cell host and microbe that icam 5
telencephalon is a functional entry
receptor for enterovirus d68
and so because of this
growth in cases it was interesting to
investigate how
exactly does this infection happen but
after the infection
what happens is that there are virus
host interaction
so when the host cells face pathogenic
microbes
different pattern recognition receptors
or prrs
are expressed by the host cell to
recognize viral components
through pathogen-associated molecular
patterns pimps
that trigger intracellular signaling
cascades to activate
pro-inflammatory responses so primarily
we're talking about interferon secretion
stimulating ifn stimulated genes as
genes to activate the antiviral state of
the host cell
enteroviruses are mainly recognized by
three prrs
toe-like receptors tlr's retinoic
acid inducible gene one like receptors
and nod like receptors nlrs
a tlr-3 trif complex activates a
signaling pathway
and interacts with ikk related kinase
complexes resulting in phosphorylation
of
ifn regulatory factor 3. so
once the virus gets into the cell
you have this interferon response that
triggers this cascade of immune
responses
and what's important to understand is
that
the non-structural viral proteins like
2ac 3a
and 3c can suppress interferon
production
allowing for replication advantage
because what
happens in the host cell when the virus
enters and it is successfully recognized
within the cell there's this trigger for
the interferon response
which causes the cell to shut down
production and signal
on the membrane to other cells around it
that
something bad is going on and so for the
virus to effectively replicate
it has to sabotage this process
before it can enter its rna into the
production machinery to produce its own
proteins so that the virions can
actually reproduce and
get out of this cell and so these
non-structural proteins
suppress this interferon production and
um there are a lot of
kind of specifics here so 3c
was shown to cleave trif at its amino
and carboxyl
terminal domains leading to tripp's
inability to activate
nfkbs and interferon gamma signaling
helping virus to escape immune response
of the host
okay so um what the what comes out of
this is that
specific cell cycle phases may actually
affect viral production
so uh the cell goes into different
phases and so g0
g1 phase promotes viral production
whereas g2
m phase inhibits it and it is controlled
by edd68 through regulation of
expression
of cyclins and cdks so cyclin d cdk2
cdk4 cdk6 and cyclin e
are down regulated after viral infection
in order to inhibit transition
from the geo g0 g1 phase to s
phase which is a less favorable phase
for viral production
and cyclin b1 and cdk1 promote
transition from g2
m to g0 g1 phases so as a result
we have this complex regulatory
machinery that this virus has
first of all to adapt to different types
of receptors
again to cause disease in the neural
tissue it has to attach to these
uh to these specific icam 5's
as opposed to i can ones or i can force
and it has to also successfully inhibit
uh this interferon response from the
cell recognition
to be able to replicate so this
effective replication
in the neural tissue in the spine is
what causes damage to the spine
but it also causes this kind of
evolution from the viral
perspective causing a diversity
right and so this diversity
can be characterized just like i showed
in the first part of this presentation
with ama1
we can think of haplotypes in two
different ways
so the first way is when we have
consensus sequences from a population
and we are looking at population genetic
level
diversity so we're actually trying to
combine
all of the different variations that we
have at the consensus level
into a smaller number of groups so what
we did with ama1
is we had let's say 350 sequences
and we reduced that number to about a
half so maybe 150.
in this case when we're talking about
viral haplotypes
we're actually talking about an increase
in diversity so for
each sample we actually have multiple
substrains and these substrates are
actually
called haplotypes because each infection
is represented by a group of somewhat
diverse viruses and so the goal here
is to look at individual reads and then
combine those reads
into haplotypes that represent a single
sample
okay why does this happen why does this
virus
evolution take place and how
recombination and mutations caused by
the error-prone polymerase that lacks a
proof-reading mechanism
have been recognized as the main
mechanism for enterovirus evolution
recombination plays a crucial role in
viral evolution and adaptation
by repre by repairing deleterious
mutations in genomes
thus rescuing fit viral genomes from low
fitness parents
moreover it provides the ability for
large evolutionary transitions
otherwise known as jumps in the fitness
landscape by producing in a single step
significantly divergent genomes
better adapted to new environments the
role of recombination in entire viruses
has been summarized
uh by you know in in the early 2000s
but since then a great number of studies
have been published providing new
insights into the evolution of the
members of this genera
and the primary driver behind these new
discoveries
is this next generation sequencing
approach that allows us
to accurately detect individual genomes
and categorize them as a single
haplotype and the projects that i
mentioned before
including the project about polio with
low
fi with low frequency mutations and
their ability to affect the fitness of
viral populations causing disease
is a good way to get started with that
project
now if you want to learn a lot more
about the biology and the background of
this project
we recommend going to this project it's
only
ten dollars on the edu t-bio info
platform and for those of you that are
already a part of our
bioinformatics for infectious disease
program this is included in the program
itself
what you will find here is a very
detailed overview of everything that
i've briefly described today
so let me show you how to get there
okay so this is again the project
here you will find the project overview
and
then you will be able to go into the
background of enterovirus 368 how it
causes disease what are the infection
mechanisms
test your own knowledge about this
process and then
get an introduction to the different
analysis methods that we will go
on to next to discuss how you actually
analyze this type of data so for those
of you that are interested
in following along and having all of the
background of what i am describing
please go into this um
project right here
okay thank you
okay so let's talk about the data
okay what is the data that we are going
to be dealing with and before we talk
about the data
i wanted to mention that we are going to
be using
the tower bioinformatics research
center's platform
called t-bioinfo and so this t-value
info
allows you to process large data sets
including rna-seq data perform analysis
from a statistical perspective explore
machine learning algorithms that you can
apply to different types of data sets
perform multi-articles integration and
provide you with several tools for
biological interpretation so all that
we're going to be speaking about today
the practical part is going to be on
the t-biome for platform how do you get
access to the tbi info platform
so the first way is you can register on
learn.omicslogic.com if you don't have
an account
just by registering that there for free
uh beeps if you can again post the link
you will receive an
email that will give you a demo
access to this platform so this demo
access
will allow you to try pipelines without
actually
running any analysis just to kind of see
input
the logic of analysis and the output
another way to do this is by actually
going
to server.tbioinfo which i will do right
now
okay and here you can actually request
access by filling out this form
okay so what i will do again is i will
just give here
a couple of moments uh for those of you
that do not have an account
so um if i may ask uh
that you put into the chat box again
how many of you do not have an account
on this platform because
the whole next session is the section of
this workshop is going to deal with
a practical analysis of data from this
evd68 infection
so please put in number three if you do
not have an account
on the t bioinfo platform
okay so it looks like um joseph
christian so okay so uh joseph
and kazeem uh anu
could you please go to
learn.omixlogic.com
and register there it will literally
take a minute
and you should get an email back that
will give you
the details of your account so i'll just
demonstrate how to do that
for those of you that are just joining
for the first time
you're going to learn
again i'm actually going to log out real
quick
and then what you can do is you can go
to register for
free right here
and create an account so you can either
sign in
if you have an account or create an
account and when you do that
you can create a new account i'm just
going to be uh
john uh let's see
smith and then here i'll just
you know use a strong password and then
i can
sign up i'm not going to do that because
i already have an account
but once you do that you will actually
receive an email
and it will give you access here but it
will also
give you access to the server t-biomefor
platform okay so i'm just going to give
it
a couple of minutes and uh please
uh joseph kazeem anu
and elham if you could please complete
the registration let me know
that you are there maybe you can just
put it in chat
and that way i will be able to see that
you're already
registered and ready to follow along
okay please let me know maybe you can
put let's say number four
in the chat box so we're making progress
we already went from one
two three and four so let me know i will
just do it
one more minute for you to finish
all right thank you
all right so as we are moving along uh
let me kind of introduce this type of
data
to you so that you know where this data
is coming from
so all of you are probably familiar with
uh
okay thank you kazeem uh so all of you
are probably familiar with
ncbi so let's try to find this data
on ncbi and then i will give you
actually data that you can
use for this analysis today okay so ncbi
contains next generation sequencing and
first generation sequencing data from a
variety
of different types of data so
here i have the link to the bio project
i'm going to
share it here on chat and you can see in
this bio project that these are
full genome sequencing of european evd68
samples
from 2014 2016 and 2018
and ongoing epidemics in order to better
understand
evd68 evolution and phylodynamics right
so remember
what we saw on next strain is exactly
what we're seeing
here and then you have here
113 sra experiments so if you click on
this link
you will see here a list of those
samples
so let me ask you uh for those of you
that are following along
uh what are these uh data sets so what
what do you think was actually
sequenced in these data sets
okay anyone is just free to put your
answer in the chat we'll kind of see how
familiar you are with the different
types of data that is hosted here on
ncbi
okay go ahead cezanne
sir um the basis of the sequence
i mean the dna sequence the basis
okay all right great and then uh abi
manu is saying
rna-seq so uh
blood samples for rna io is saying okay
so let's talk about azad's
answer first of all he mentioned that
this is a
dna sequences of blood samples so
this is a patient sample but
what is extracted from that patient
sample is the enterovirus t68 which as
you remember is an rna
virus but it's not rna-seq in the sense
that it measures
uh expression of genes this is uh
if we click here we'll actually see what
this
data is okay so the dna preparations
were quantified using quantity
gm ds dna high sensitivity safe kit and
decan spark 10 and plate reader
so they took
let's just get to the interesting part
of it okay so here
the library was quantified using
quantity mds dna high sequencing essay
kit and the can spark 10 and plate
review
to a depth of one hundred thousand one
million reads per sample
on a high seek 2500 illumina sequencer
base calling and demultiplexing was done
using bcl2 fast qv
version 1.87 without allowing any
mismatch
in the index sequence so let's
deconvolute what this actually means
what that means is that they extracted
the
viral so they amplified specifically
viral sequences
right so you can create a primer amplify
that using pcr
and then what you get is an amplified
sequence of viruses
that are present in a given blood sample
after that you can see that the
sequencing was done to a depth of 100
000 that's pretty good depth so it
allows
good coverage across the genome for us
to be able to perform this kind of
analysis
uh on high seek 2500 which is a good
length of read and high throughput
output from this
sequencer and then as you know once you
sequence your samples on the aluminum
machine you actually have to combine
them because they
are combined together into a single
plate
so you need to use the barcodes to
separate individual samples
into fast q files and so from this
run which is the bcl you get
multiple fast queues and so they use
this uh
script called vcl2 fastq which is
published by illumina
so you can get individual fast q files
so this is why it is called amplicon
and it is of viral rna through
rt pcr and the layout is paired so
why do we use paired reads to be able to
analyze these sequences the reason is
because it provides us with more uh
more reliable sequences and the ability
to perform
error correction okay so let's go on
let's take a look at the specific so as
you can see
there are 113
sequences here and so out of these
sequences we actually want to
select specific ones okay so let's take
a look at which ones do we want to take
you can see that we have uh one two
three
four five six seven eight nine
nine of them and you can see that they
come from years 2014
2016 and 2018.
so we actually want to take samples that
represent
this uh change happening over time
okay let's go back really quickly to
next string
okay so this is our 2014 right here
then we have 2016 right here
and then we have 2018
right here right so those are the
samples
that we would like to take 2014 2016
2018. now we also have
matching samples that are gene bank
so these are assembled consensus
sequences they're not
fast q files which contain individual
reads these are actually assembled files
that allow us to know the consensus
sequence or the most
prevalent sequence in a given file so
these are genbank
files and genbank files have also the
reference genome
which was first sequenced as you
remember in california in 1962
all right so to gain access to all of
these files i'm not going to
bother you with actually finding all of
these individual sequences
but i will just first show you how would
you go about it how would you if you
find a data set
on ncbi how do you actually download
the sequence ids so that you can process
them
on the tbi info platform okay so the way
to do this
is you go to ncdi right here
and what you can do is you can send
results to run selector
the run selector provides you a view of
all of the different types of metadata
and your sample ids right here
you can see where it was collected uh
spot lengths uh
kind of average links and stuff like
that and so what you can do is you can
download
metadata the metadata will provide
additional information
for example location of data collection
year of data collection
etc but here it's useful because you can
actually
navigate between the different pages
because we have so many samples
and let's try to find some of these
samples real quickly
so as you can see we have here 507
4 507 and 5 5076
okay let's try to find these so here we
have 5 0 7 4
5 6
4 5 6 50 54 56
okay so 50
54 56
now it can go on top over here and well
let's get the rest of them so 50 54
56 and then 44 96 and 100 so let's find
44. again the 96
and 100 would actually be
on the next page so go to
the next uh okay well let's keep it at
this so we have one two three
four five six seven so we have seven
samples right here
and i can get the metadata
to see what is in these samples
so what i get is a file coil
sra table.txt
if you look inside this txt file you can
see that actually everything is
separated by comma
so you need to change it to a csv which
is what i did here
and now you can see what are the
specific
uh things like for example
all of these were from sweden right
and then you can move over here
and you can see that indeed they were
all sequenced by illumina hi-c
2500 and these were all enterovirus d68
um and then here you can actually see
the string
so here you see b3 string which are the
first four samples and b1 string
the second three samples right so
they're actually different
let's see if they give us okay and they
give us the date so this one
is from 2018 these three are
from 2016 and these three are from 2014.
okay let's go back and again check with
what we know
about these strings so here we have b1
strain
[Music]
here we have the b3 string right so what
we see is that the b1 strain
which was predominantly in the u.s
just kind of died off right there have
not been
any new samples collected after 2014
but the b3 strain is kind of more
fit it's more able to continue and
replicate
and cause these outbreaks over the years
and so we see that
first indeed it happened in 2014 at the
same time that we saw this outbreak
then it moved on and we see this other
outbreak in 2016
and then we have this other outbreak in
2018
which is also predominantly d3
okay so what if we wanted to take these
files
and upload them to the platform so here
let's forget about all the other
information
i only took this the ids of these links
and let's go to the platform now for
those of you that are using
the demo platform you actually cannot
upload the files yourselves you can use
the demo pipeline
but i will for those of you that do have
access i'll just demonstrate
how this works so out of this whole uh
section of areas of analysis where we
have next generation sequencing data
processing
uh here we have a section for data
integration modeling
and one of those is on the phylogeny so
let's go to this
phylogenetic tree you can see that we
can
map our data to the reference genome
and here we will be able to determine
the haplotypes
but before we do that does somebody
remember whether these were fast q
files and whether they were single end
or pair edge does anybody remember what
they were
all right i was paying attention pair to
end thank you io um
so we will change this right here to
paired ends
and then i have to go to step number two
which is upload next generation
sequencing data
now i'm not going to download multiple
megabytes and gigabytes
to my computer instead i want to
directly upload them from ncbi
so right here i have ncbi run table
upload
and i can just go to add files
and select this accession list right
here
to upload it to my uh
pipeline builder so now i have to
separate them into groups okay how would
you propose to separate them
into groups
what are some phenotypic categories that
you can think of that could help us
separate them into groups
all right excellent rasheen is also
paying attention that's group
that's good rasheed maybe you could
suggest
how would you separate them into what
groups would it be two groups
three groups
all right excellent thank you i have
three groups so let's create three
groups
now let's go back to our table and we'll
take a look at
what are the samples since he said by
year we'll do it by year so we have this
first sample
this is 5 0 44. so 5
0 44 we'll drag it to 2018 will be
our group c
then we have here uh 2016
which are 50 54 and 56
so 50 54
and 56 and here we have the rest of them
which are all 2014 and they are 74 75
and 76
so 74 75
and 76 all right so now we have
um out group for framing okay
what could that mean what does it mean
to have an
out group for framing so an output for
framing is a group of files that
allows us to associate a particular
haplotype a set of
co-occurring mutations with a defined
consensus genome right and so here i'm
just going to
get my links for those of you
for those of you that are following
along uh
i will give you the links
all right so here are the links for
those of you
that are interested to kind of perform
the full
analysis these are the links
to the individual um tables that you
would need the first one
is the sra run table we showed you how
to do that
and then you see here we have two out
groups for 1962
right that's the reference genome and
the 2013
consensus okay so let's go and take this
this is a gene bank file
okay so you can see this is a gene being
file
it has the translation of these
uh sequences of nucleotide two amino
acid sequences so let's go ahead and say
file
uh save as okay i'm just gonna
save it to downloads
again here i don't need the txt so it's
a gb
and then the second one
was this one
okay now i could
download them to my computer right
and then i have to add those files right
so let me
this is outgroup2 file save as
and now i need to add them right here
okay and then here i can add
another one
and then i need and then i need
the viral genome so again i have that
right here
okay that is the reference genome so
actually i
don't think i need it but this is
all right now we're going to build our
pipeline
so first of all uh you can read a little
bit more about phylogenetic analysis
here
that can either work with faster files
or fast q files essentially looking at
multiple sequence alignment and
phylogeny based on consensus genome
or what's called sub consensus analysis
which is looking at what's within
those individual reads and analyzing
that data together so i'm going to click
on
ok and now you can see that each job
is organized into different types of
sections
okay and so here you can see that i have
mapping so i will use bow type 2
bow tie 2 is an algorithm that has been
optimized from bow tie 1
to map efficiently using you know
optimization of memory usage for mapping
onto the reference genome so i'm going
to use this one
and then here you can see that i can
create sample consensus
okay so if i wanted to take all of my
reads
and create a fasta file from each one of
those next generation sequencing read
raw files for fast u i could go to here
but instead what i will do in this case
is i will skip alignment to the
reference genome and go directly to
haplotypes
and this is a method called sho ra
shora maybe it is a computational method
for inferring the structure of
haplotypes from sequencing of mixed
samples so again if you imagine
multiple types of viruses combined
together in a single blood sample how do
we now
separate them into the actual viral
sequences that we expect to be present
there
okay so here we have some specific
settings
including the window size because again
we're looking for a specific combination
of mutations
that can categorize essentially an
assembled genome so we're sort of
performing
an assembly based on all the sequencing
reads that we have
okay and so here we'll click on save
then we'll perform multiple sequence
alignments
we'll convert that multiple sequence
alignment to amino acid sequences
we can also look at specific mutational
profiles in the third
codon position which we don't need to do
in this case
and then we have a series of
phylogenetic methods from multiple
sequence alignment
using venetian or neighbor joining
algorithms like ape
which provides us with several different
options there so we will
use the coalescent option what is the
coalescent constant size
it assumes that unknown constant
population size
back through time so essentially what we
are looking at
typically is the divergence and
coalescence meaning
their common ancestor
is sometime in the past
and since coalescence is a process
directed back to work in time
in opposite direction of the divergence
it is not advised for speciation
times estimation so in other words
typically
you would use it for evolutionary
relationship
not for divergence over time with
a specific time allocation
okay so then what are we using here
we're using
nuclear time and we will click
on end
and we can save the pipeline
and click save and run this
on the cluster
all right so once our pipeline has
started we will
have to wait a little bit for this to be
completed and now let me skip on
to the results
okay so for those of you that are
following along here's a link
to a pipeline that has finished
so this pipeline that has finished
provides us with
several different outputs so here you
can see
the input was translated into a fasta
file
so let's take a look the fasta file and
the cluster files
are almost identical and allow us to
view
the consensus sequences aligned together
for all of the haplotypes remember that
this is for all of the haplotypes
then you can see that we have a pdf file
of the phylogenetic tree so let's take a
look at that
pdf file
okay so here we have a pdf file
and uh harpreet did you have the time to
prepare something to speak about these
results yes celia
okay so i will pass it on to for pre to
describe the results of this pipeline
okay clear thank you
can you just make me co-host
okay thank you
so now let me share my slides sorry
this plane
okay so i have already downloaded this
a pdf file so if i just go to this
so here what you will find like if
this is like a phylogenetic tree now if
you look at this phylogenetic tree
though you will find three major plates
like this one
this one and this one so here if i
show you what it contains like here
these are the haploid
the first one is showing the out group
so this is the out group uh
that belongs to 2013 then we have a
reference you know
so then this first one first out group
that is
belong to the year 2000 1962
so then it is making completely distinct
cluster
uh uh completely disney played so then
this is
a particular this out group uh have
taken from 2013
and then this is group one sample so if
you remember we have taken samples from
three different years like 2016
uh 2016 uh 2012 and 2014.
so here each year is actually making a
different
uh clade itself here within this you
will find
multiple haplotypes so like here for the
group
two which is uh 2016.
so sorry 2013 and
uh this is the third group uh which is
2016. so we have
all the three groups from three
different years
and what we have observed haplotype of
each year
actually clustered together on this
particularly
single phylogenetic tree and each
year these haplotypes from each year
also making a
completely different clusters so then
this particular
uh out group that is outgroup time point
so this is the different
how you can find actually which uh which
group is close to which here for example
this was already this particular
reference genome is
also taken from from the year 2013
and this is also taken this out group is
also taken from 2013 so they are more or
close to the 2012
so then the completely the 2000 this is
2018 and 2016.
so we can also understand but uh what is
the relationship between these
haplotypes as well as these different
clusters so whether they are different
from each other or not
so this is based on the phylogenetic
analysis
itself so then apart from that we have
here on in our results if you want to
understand what are the mutations are
taking place
between the uh samples from
different reasons so this is if you just
download this table that is full
uh full table tsv so which and ending
here
so you will find also the what are the
important mutations maybe
are in these groups so one can find out
the butter important mutations
and then that is that nucleotide as well
as amino
acid labels so here like at each
position what are
mutations are taking place in each each
of these haplotypes
so you uh if you further i want to
analyze this
you can find but a different mutation
like over the years
from 2012 outbreak to
2018 outbreak what are the important
mutations that are taking place between
these kind of samples
we can actually analyze that at the
haplotype level itself
so these are the results that i just
want to suggest if you have any other
question
you can ask and please go ahead and ask
if you have any question regarding
phylogenetic tree
or this mutational analysis
all right thank you and so for the
purpose of time
because we don't have a lot of time left
i want to
actually pick up here to talk briefly
about the significance of this type of
analysis why is it useful
what is it useful for for example right
now
so as uh harpreed explained
you can see how the different groups by
year
are separated into a certain number of
haplotypes and so the immediate
outcome here is you can start looking at
how
divergent each group is and you can see
that
this group has a smaller number of
haplotypes as opposed to
this group in group number three so you
can just count the number of haplotypes
and that is one method of inference what
do you
get out of this type of an analysis
another one
is that these right here are proportions
so these numbers are proportions of how
many reads are proportionate to the
total number of reads
that contain these haplotypes so you can
look at
the number of positions that are mutated
per each haplotype because
as harpreet showed we have this full
table of
sequences and their coding and
non-coding mutations
and you can start comparing how diverse
they are
and where the specific positions that
are influenced
by this evolutionary process
now this was an example with evd68 but a
similar story
is known to happen even with source code
2 which we're all familiar with
so interestingly there was recently a
publication
that describes quasi species in the
context
of source cove 2. so here you can see
the representation of the impact of
comorbidity
on source code 2 quasi species
generation and testing
so here you can see how comorbidities
and different types of symptomatic and
asymptomatic response could allow
a different type of evolutionary
pressure on these
communities of viruses causing disease
eventually
causing the spread as well and so one of
the things that has been proposed is
that different populations with
different comorbidities
different types of phenotypes different
kind of genetic background
could cause diversion between these
quasi species
and a lower level of detection by the
common standard method of rt-pcr
so it's a very important topic
especially in pandemics like today to be
able to
link the diversity not only the
diversity of
phenotypes not only to a specific clade
but also to the diversity within that
plate which could be defined by
haplotypes
and so that's why we're also going to be
looking at
how to utilize some of these similar
types of analysis
you can see here that we did today uh
shora
right analysis of haplotype consensus
sequences
with a more general approach
that will allow us to detect low
frequency mutations
that could indicate prevalence of
specific variants
and so in conclusion of today's webinar
i wanted to let you know
that coming up we have another webinar
um on the genomic surveillance of source
code 2
to detect variants of concern right
so how can we utilize this type of an
analysis
to actually be able to find and
understand
the trends behind the emergence of
source code 2
to perform genomic surveillance how to
collect data
how could it be sequenced and what are
some of the bioinformatics analysis
methods that allow us to detect these
important
variants of concern how to perform
downstream analysis of genomic data
with evolutionary studies like we did
today but also to trace origin
and to report the variance of concern or
specific
clades based on different nomenclature
that's out there like pangolin and
others
to be able to report about presence of
specific clades
and then just to build a report how do
you actually build a report what are
some of the considerations around
coverage
specific proportions of variance
positions how do you identify
positions to look for for these plates
and then also to discuss some future
directions for large-scale vaccination
and variant of concern monitoring
so again as you know there are many
different distinct
source code 2 clades and variants that
define them
these have been over the time separated
into
more and more numbers of clades and so
it's important to continuously monitor
those
here's an example where you have
specific non-synonymous and synonymous
mutations that define
this is the 20i or the b117 uk
variant you can see that it started in
the uk about
november 2020 and it's prevalent today
in the uk but also starting to appear
in other areas like the us so you can
see here
different clades in the u.s and these
are the mutations in the spike protein
that of course
potentially have an implication for the
different types of
infection phenotypes that we're
observing in the population
now to detect these we need to
understand the genomic
organization the specific mutation
rates that are of interest and are of
concern
as well as some of the validation of
those variants that for example here you
can see for the amino acid 614
d that has been confirmed with higher
transmission rates
so we'll actually take a look at the
structure and organization of the genome
the particular regions that imply
specific function
how this function could be monitored and
understand and
understood in the context of genetic
background of different patients
then how we can actually link the
mutability of individual positions
with an understanding of those regions
that are highly variable
where we expect these variants of
concern to be expect
to get established and what is the
effect of some of the selective
pressures
as we have the large-scale vaccination
and treatment of source to infection
with symptomatic and asymptomatic cases
as well as different types of variation
that just emerge as a result of this
long-term infection that is observed now
importantly it has been shown that this
has an
impact on uh the ability of vaccines to
cause
a long-lasting immune response and so
this is not just to understand what's
happening
this is also to be able to anticipate
how these changes will impact the future
rollout of vaccines
and the modification of these vaccines
with potential
boosting shots that we'll be expecting
and so we'll talk about some of these
variants of concern
we'll also talk about some of the
additional things that
are not as highly described in
literature
not just mutations but actual long
deletions that are observed in long-term
kind of
infection studies and we'll talk about
the national
open genomics consortium for the coca-19
response
or spheres what is nih what is cdc doing
to address some of these topics and so
if you want to learn about this
consensus level analysis of variance
detection of novel prevalent variants
subconsensus and low frequency variance
detection of variance of concern in low
quality samples for example
in wastewater and tracking
the spread and the emergence of variants
in densely populated areas
we invite you to join uh this upcoming
webinar and actually a program a whole
program
uh and thank you sir for posting this
link
in the chat box uh this is the link
for you to learn more about this and to
register
for the webinar you just have to submit
your information right here
and then we will again email you some of
the details
about how to actually perform this
analysis now importantly
we're not just going to be talking about
it it's not going to be
so the webinar is going to describe the
topics but we will
be doing some hands-on analysis
uh starting from describing different
methods
of sequencing looking at
files and understanding what types of
files they are
looking at different ways we can analyze
this data
including specific types of funding
opportunities that you could pursue
if you are conducting such type of
sequencing and analysis
examples from the studies that we've
been involved in for wastewater
sequencing
methods of analysis on the t-bind for
platform
for an in-depth characterization of
variants and what they do how do they
impact and how to measure the impact
using
different types of metrics and and then
we'll also
look at actually preparing a report on
your own
uh using the outputs of these pipelines
but only focusing
on particular important features that
include
analysis of per protein
sequence analysis uh different types of
sample analysis and then also the impact
of
pre-processing as you can see right here
with
trimmatic and pcr clean and some
reporting
how to write a script in r so that you
can
highlight the important features and
this is going to be based on
a sample report that will download from
cosmos
id which is a company that um
offers to generate reports uh for
source both to clinical samples so we'll
we'll make a report exactly like what
they do
based on coverage and specific variants
of concern
like you can see here the uk variant and
so we'll do that in
r using ggplot and using some
additional libraries that are going to
be useful for data manipulation
so thank you again for uh joining in
today uh we look
forward to seeing you in this upcoming
webinar uh
that's going to happen uh um
at a future date and i'll pass it on to
pipsa to talk about the details thank
you
thank you so much elia for that overview
so let me go ahead and share my stream
again
so that i can introduce you to the
upcoming
webinar so as you know we are going to
be doing hands-on
sessions so if you have not yet created
an account
please go ahead and create an account on
learn.org logic that will also give you
an
access to the tbio info platform and
and if you're facing any problem you can
reach out to us at marketing
at find.bio
for setting up that account so that by
our next webinar which is going to be
happening
on april 29th so the webinar is going to
be on april 29th and this is
these are the dates of the program so
let us just take a quick
look at the different dates of the
program so we will be starting on third
may which is monday and going on till
friday
and these are the topics that will be
covered
in this workshop and the total cost of
this workshop is only 50
so if you're interested in joining again
you can email us and we will be sending
you
a link to join this workshop but for the
webinar next week
you just have to fill out the form and
we will be sending you details of
how to join both the webinar as well as
the
full workshop so besides this workshop
on sar scope 2 we also have some
programs coming up which
if you are interested you can join so we
have the
biomedical data science and drug
discovery program that is starting on
april 26th this is a
full four months program which is going
to be starting
on april 26 with genomics
then with met transcriptomics on may 19
june 14th we will start to talk about
data science
and from june 12th to july 19th we'll
also have sessions on chemo informatics
again if you need
more details regarding this you can fill
out
the form at the end of the page
and the third program that we have
coming starting this friday
is a two day workshop on
precision oncology with a focus on
lymphoma data this we are
doing in collaboration with the all
india institute of medical sciences new
delhi
and the cost of this workshop is 2000
indian rupees so if you're again
interested you can register for this
webinar and
register for this workshop and you can
reach out to me for any details
for all of you who are interested in
being updated about all of the upcoming
free webinars as well as sessions we
have this page which
you may have already registered in so
we'll send you the updates
to join these sessions and again if you
have any questions
please feel free to reach out to us and
post them in the chat box especially
related to whatever we have spoken about
today and when you run those
analysis on your owner explorer
platforms if you come across any
questions please feel free to
post those questions to us for at
marketing at find.bio
and i hope that you have followed us on
our facebook
and linkedin pages we are active
on both these platforms as also on
instagram and you will be able to not
only learn about
the upcoming programs in sessions but
you'll also be able to
work and interact with a lot more people
who
come from bioinformatics biotechnology
and life sciences two men and gives you
an opportunity
to learn about all the interesting
research that is going on
around the world in related to
bioinformatics we keep on posting about
interesting articles publications and
topics in these groups
so please keep a watch out there so i
hope that you really enjoyed today's
session we hope to see you at
the upcoming webinar on the variant
analysis and detection of starscope 2
and thank you all again for joining
today's session have a wonderful
day ahead
okay so the cost for the aims workshop
is 2000 inr
so if you are not in india you can
convert it to the local currency to see
uh what is the cost but as this is
organized
uh in collaboration with us with uh the
aims new at delhi so
it is priced in inr if you have any
questions or you want to join the
workshop and still have
one more day tomorrow so please reach
out to us
and okay so the total cost uh would be
26.53 us dollars
for this workshop it's only a two-day
workshop
and it will be from 10 a.m ist to 5 p.m
ist which may be from the western
hemisphere
it may be night time for you
but we will of course be recording the
sessions and
sending it to everybody so if you are
still interested in joining please let
us know
you can reach out to me for any of these
details
so thank you all again for joining we'll
send you
the recording of today's session as well
and you can find it not posted on all of
our social media very shortly
and we'll see you at the upcoming
sessions have a lovely day
you